after a right-wing anti-semitic anti-vax
Q Anon Trump is nut broke into Nancy
Pelosi's house and hit her husband over
the head with a hammer
Fox News uh anchor Jesse Waters said
listen a lot of people get hit with
hammers
and if they hadn't defunded the police
in San Francisco which didn't happen
maybe this wouldn't have taken place
it's unbelievable but this is what
they're going with take a listen to this
what I want is that I want this alleged
perpetrator to be treated the exact same
way if he had treated if he had attacked
anybody else because a lot of people get
hit with hammers what a lot of people
get attacked and a lot of the times
they're out on bail the next day and
it's a simple assault charge so I don't
know why this guy is being treated
differently and he's facing what
attempted homicide he's in prison right
now we see people assault people all the
time randomly with all kinds of weapons
and we see them released the next day
not not super tough on crime when it's
trumpist rioters on January 6th or a
middle of the night home invasion these
are the types of home invasions that the
Wright loves to say this is when you
just shoot them with your self-defense
gun they love talking about home
invasions and yet now he's like well the
guy's actually being treated potentially
too harshly too harshly usually you say
these people can be shot I don't know
why this guy is getting all of a sudden
special treatment or different treatment
because the victim was so high profile
remember if you call on a welfare check
the left wants to send a social worker
what if a social worker had come to this
call he would have it dead
husband and you would have had a dead
social worker yeah I have not seen nor
have I suggested that social workers be
sent out to middle of the night home
invasions where their targeted attacks I
I have never said that I've not heard
people on the left side that say that I
have heard hey you know if you have a
homeless person where police are called
because they're sleeping on a business
stoop maybe then you send a social
worker maybe if you have you know some
kind of minor drug situation but anyway
they have to they have no choice but to
put up these Straw Men in order to tear
them down now you have to hand it to
them on the one hand they spent a week
when the Fox News Christmas tree was
vandalized no victims no individual
victims and a week they spend on that
and now it's listen a lot of people get
hit with hammers a lot of people get hit
with hammers it is truly unbelievable
and then also saying this is because of
the defunding of police
there has been almost no defunding of
police anywhere in the country
and the police department budget in San
Francisco is up more than four percent
since 2019. Waters and others love to
say they've defunded the police that's
why this is happening but they've not
defunded the police and it has nothing
to do with it it actually the Hammers
thing reminds me of the good liars
remember our friends the good liars went
to the NRA convention and this this guy
they talked to tried to talk about
Hammers and it went South very quickly
or people and more crime is committed
and more people are killed with hammers
every year than guns
look at the packs I will look that up I
don't think that's true actually it's
true in the United States though sir
that is true look it up it's on you can
Google it it's true it's actually true
so the number of murder victims and the
weapons used okay number one
handguns
8029 number two Firearms type not stated
4863 number three niser cutting
instruments personal weapons fists feet
uh then rifles
at 455 then blunt objects clubs hammers
uh
393. the the 300 the Hammers that that
stat is just wrong back to your question
Second Amendment is still my right and
it's still important to me everything I
said was wrong about the Hammers but I
still want my guns and then one more
clip here check out how Fox News covers
the attack
and manages to completely omit the
entire political backstory of the
individual the fact that he's a Maga nut
Q Anon anti-semite Kanye loving
now police have not stated a motive for
this attack the suspect in this case de
Pepe is reportedly from the Bay Area
from Berkeley Fox digital reports that
this suspect has ties to a radical
nudist activist and has a disturbing
online presence that involves the online
presence is disturbing posts about
pedophiles Big Brother censorship and
anti-semitic content and lawmakers
while swiftly condemned this attack on
Pelosi yesterday former vice president
Mike Pence says this suspect should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law now yeah what a completely Anodyne
way to stay listen this is a radical and
everybody condemned it it's like hold on
a second the right Wingers generically
condemn it while completely ignoring the
basis politically for what this guy did
and what his beliefs were
and it is of course deliberate that they
are doing that so not an altogether
shocking response from the right let's
go to one more little chapter on this
related to the new Twitter owner Elon
Musk before you go if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more please make
sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel
you can click the Subscribe button below
or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David Pacman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description